well hello there citizens of the reject Nation
we're here and it is time for another solo
movie reaction to Nicholas Cage and John Travolta
in the 1997 Sci-Fi Action epic face off that's
right peeps somehow I have made it decades
through this life well into 2023 now without
ever having seen face off I could not be more
excited I feel like it's rare these days that
you get to go into a movie with this particular
blend of anticipation but also just pure bewildered
curiosity I have heard so much about this
movie over the years and yet somehow I feel
like I have absolutely no idea what to expect
even still which is just a feeling I'm going
to save her as we proceed here uh but needless
to say I'm a huge Nick Cage fan from Moonstruck
to Mandy Raising Arizona too many films to
name he has turned in some of my favorite
performances over the years Big Love for John
Travolta as well these two are prolific and
I cannot wait to see what kind of weird Sparks
Fly as they Collide here in this film but
hey guys before we hop in why don't you leave
a like on the video that would be very much
appreciated subscribe and hit that notification
Bell and if you want to get the full Fresh
Off experience come on over to patreon.com
the railragex sync up with your own copy and
see everything that doesn't make these reaction
highlights thank you to prepper for editing
these down and without further Ado guys It's
Time To Face Off
[Music] that's right oh man okay so this will
be like Peak crossover woo oh I'm getting
excited
you don't get a lot of Firsts like this you
know
it's like an alternate universe version of
The Punisher about to happen right now Thomas
Jane one
[Music] [Laughter] God already it's wasting
no time [Music]
[Music] it's all the eyes that mustache too
where is this in relation to Raising Arizona
they're just having the best day oh yeah
oh [Music] no Innocence Lost
[Music] oh no oh my [Music] God oh god oh
no oh poor guy punch me up man you got it
[Music] [Laughter] Caster Troy okay finally
put a a face to the name to the face off I've
heard yeah cause I've heard the name Caster
Troy but I never realized that was that was
this
Sinclair is hot
[Laughter] this is a fascinating amalgamation
of tones and and feelings and all sorts of
things even here the first three minutes
oh what it's reminding me of like a James
Bond meets Da Vinci Code thing with him but
now it's [Music] oh
[Music]
Jesus the meme [Laughter] where are we in
relation to when Rush Hour was there Convention
Center that jet was just charted Anderson
Airfield guess who paid the bill in cash Pollock's
Troy put one of our people on that plane Pollux
Castor and Pollux the cast like the constellation
shouts out to all my Geminis and my Greek
and Roman mythology majors [Music]
[Laughter] all the crane shots and slo-mos
and walking and flapping and everything
[Music]
is that
all drugs and then Chiclets that's good buddy
and love you so damn much I'd have to kill
you bro I hate it when you call me bro don't
see Avatar the way of water you guys are paid
to protect them from everybody including himself
and stay away from downtown on the 18th it's
going to be a little um smoggy oh jeez it's
good brotherly love would you like anything
else once we're airborne a peach you know
I can uh
if I were too late my tongue would you be
grateful oh no
I'm very disoriented but this is quite fun
I'm having a very good time [Music] look at
that heat as they bring the heat Archer
Archer damn the things you do for the batch
a little over under cranking on that shot
nice uh cool Dutch angle shot to pull into
no matter how dramatic it's still freaking
awesome
[Music]
all right let's do this combo helicopter plane
Chase I'm here for it
boss oh damn
oh no oh my God
[Music] oh damn oh no oh yeah hear them Rockets
whistle hell of a plane crash
class classic the man with the golden guns
uh something tells me low bro's not gonna
make it out of this yeah
oh the ear Jesus [Music]
oh damn
oh nice wire gag [Music]
that was some ADR that was pretty sweet
God both these dudes just double fisting
[Music] sorry let's do this who's getting
sucked into the blades I'm about to unleash
the biblical plague helle deserves hello say
how is your daughter anyway your darling Janie
your little Peach oh boy oh no don't use anyone's
family members and Peach in the same sentence
ever again I better pull the trigger [Laughter]
baby sure I don't know what we as a timeline
does did to deserve Nicolas Cage but I'm happy
it happened oh boy here goes oh here it goes
oh Jesus
okay I thought he was gonna get like cheese
gratered right through that thing that's about
to be like a like Resident Evil the movie
you're all going to die down here it's like
yeah that's done left the building
nice Graceland reference or Leaving Las Vegas
you know which was the Nicholas Cage Elvis
movie you know Nicholas Cage Elvis yeah you
get the point he changed the way you look
every week who are you supposed to be now
supposed to be me not like you have a clue
who I am no it's good be yourself I got him
Eve
it's over it's over is it put in for a desk
job well I'll do counseling sit down talk
about Mike I'll do it anything you want oh
I just want you yeah
this is such a lovely scene I know I know
this isn't Gonna Last but that was I'm glad
they they took a minute for that
oh god oh hey you knew it was coming Pete
it had worse than Gulf War syndrome I'm interested
green screen this there is one other possibility
oh my I was gonna say I almost forgot the
the main premise of this movie pulled in by
all this other ridiculous chaos
oh God you're keeping him alive okay what
if you could walk into air one prison and
give Pollocks a nice big brotherly hug as
Castor Troy Dr Walsh can alter the likeness
even the voice of a government Witness what
we're suggesting for you Archer isn't a permanent
transplant like that just a temporary Trade
temporary Trade is that based on any kind
of real technology it looked sort of semi-plausible
then we simply connect the muscles tear ducts
and nerve endings so you want to take his
face in mind borrow the procedures completely
reversible sure you have lived and breathed
Castor Troy for years get his game to talk
that's what I do what if you can't the bomb
will blow and Caster Troy will win oh you
said it you said it CCH Pounder what was the
last time you saw Caster Troy hey [__]
you're right but know this you're convicted
felon on probation for harboring Castor Troy
one phone call from me and your son will end
up in a foster home oh boy but you ain't got
nothing on me and you know it or I can talk
to your sister again she's right outside hey
Sean oop how's your dead son [Music] oh geez
oh yeah okay okay I heard something about
the 18th but that's all I know good trick
with the empty chamber Jesus this is a black
bag operation you can't tell Lazaro and you
can't tell your wife excellent after that
beautiful cathartic scene I'll do it of course
yes let's go let's get one more quick Swig
of warm family life before we go back to chaos
things are gonna get better now that you're
home scar won't move but it will heal if you
will plus you got all that chest carpet to
You Know cover it up the righteous chest of
hair this thing won't fully end until I did
one last thing
oh I feel so bad for her you're going back
on assignment again this last time
oh don't do the face thing now I have a scar
that if you can put this back after it's like
a reminder sure I mean I guess they can do
anything it's a Skin lab
wow
[Music]
[Laughter] nice
[Music] way to do the gore gag without completely
showing it to you as well [Music] got like
like 20 odd minutes ago this wasn't even like
a super sci-fi movie and now and now it's
weird like this yeah it doesn't feel like
completely undergrounded and yet it is like
incredibly over the top
oh yeah get that get that re-gloving on
are you okay [Music]
yeah I still sound like me oh yeah we gotta
get you all Mission Impossible up I've been
planted a microchip on your larynx it's fantastic
but you'll have to be careful pressure sharp
blow even a violent sneeze could dislodge
it well
[Music] I could eat at a peach for hours whoa
it's got two days to get Pollock to talk either
way Miller comes in moves you out
make the most of it [Music]
cruelly a glorious and terrible burden it
must become the man he hates
it's like a unique form of torture
oh now you're in the prison from Andor prison's
one big magnetic field the boots tell us where
you are how does any machine work in this
prison hey what's up
what's up Thomas Dune
oh boy you want to see what wasted looks like
little man
whoa [Applause] just getting right down to
business jeez I guess he must I don't know
he must have as many enemies in here as he
does in law enforcement
[__] you
come on come on
God the face that launched a thousand memes
look how many more memes and like GIF Loops
is this movie gonna produce
oh [Applause] you gotta really want to kick
a guy in the nuts to override like a magnet
boot like that
whoa
[Music]
yes it's gonna be like Hollow Man interlude
laughs
foreign [Music]
cop it's cool we're gonna deal with it
oh Great Frame again
wow what do you want
pick one God guess yep
the outset it seemed like such a reasonable
question and then the truth is staring in
the face the answer I should say aren't they
giving you your medication in here what was
my medication oh I was gonna say the one part
of the Montage we didn't see was like all
the homework Alex I hand fed you those pills
for years 5x I haven't forgotten that senses
my reflexes my memory into the day it's like
a tab of bad quantracts I don't even know
why that's Yeti jumped me yesterday you had
a sandwich with his wife and his sister the
night he was sent here
that bomb you build does deserve an audience
belongs in the Louvre I guess the LA Convention
Center will have to do hey okay he's in he
did just the the right amount of homework
it's very interesting yeah because it's like
this guy's obsessed over this dude for years
he certainly knows like a ton about him but
I'm like how many of the finer yeah like only
a brother would know this details does he
have you got a visitor
[Laughter] [Music] [Applause]
[Music] now that is between us nothing like
having your face cut off to disturb your sleep
read the newspaper lately
oh oh no no oh Tito
wow I torched all the evidence that proves
you're you okay so wow looks like you're gonna
be in here for the next hundred years of course
the evidence of half the force jeez a government
job to abuse
oh God I missed that face
[Applause]
yep wow oh God what a predicament but teasing
you stop and I really hurt
hungry for you whoa Peach my peach
oh Jesus no no you're not respecting my boundaries
I'm coming in Jane Janie you something that
I crave what it is no uh when did you start
smoking you'll be seeing a lot of changes
around here
It's Got a Brand New Bag oh ow that's right
be a friend rather than a parent that's what
you really want to do I also wonder if they
had to have somebody who actually knows how
to play smoke rings for that reverse shot
the big [__] cop Archer cut them a deal
for turning States evidence your breath has
been released [Laughter] there's a bomb at
the LA Convention Center I'm Sean Archer and
now oh boy what a nightmare just to be trapped
as this guy now seeing that face on you makes
me afraid my tiramisu might come back up this
nose his hair this ridiculous chin hahaha
leave the chin that is America's chin first
before defusing the bomb what's that Worth
next question
oh my so he's just planning to live as Sean
Archer for the rest of us
living days protected by a tamper switch and
it'll take us hours to bypass evacuate your
team captain no but sir we can't we can't
disarm leave let me take care of this now
where's Chris Tucker and Jackie Chan to break
this up
huge
freaking who decides their user interfaces
I get well Pollux I guess he he designs it
from the ground up I wouldn't mind giving
him a message interception now our side's
got the ball sorry jeez you're gonna take
that it's time for a prison break I want to
thank you for uh enduring all these years
that I was an insufferable boar did you just
have a surgical procedure what was the stick
successfully removed from your ass [Laughter]
are you losing weight did you get a haircut
nope it's just Viagra also shouts out to Margaret
Cho taking us back to the 90s
what no no I'm supposed to forget all the
promises because you're going back into The
Fray oh hell of a country because the only
place I'm going is upstairs with you
you know as incredibly messed up and creepy
as this is
uh I got no end to that thought
stressed that's not creepiest how can I get
these boots off they only take them off in
the clinic right before they fry your skull
oh yeah he can withstand that he's got the
righteous indignation on his side I'm out
of cigarettes get back in line Troy I said
I'm out of cigarettes whoa yeah [Applause]
gonna go out smoking
see now you're slipping into the roll my guy
whoa oh wow can I have a light you know those
things will kill you get his boots what's
your mom doing here
I didn't touch your wife oh good but I know
your wife loves you so let's get out of here
a little more brain dead than duboff oh yeah
not bad okay
Mama it's a jailbreak good
nice oh no oh
oh damn this is a really hardcore stunts in
this movie I mean not not that I would expect
anything less from a John Woo flick but this
is it's just like so many movies crashed into
each other
[Music] yes yes
open the doors and Rain Anarchy
oh no [Music] oh this poor guy give me your
head come on oh God oh God
oh no [Music] oh climb climb
what is his sand doors he is in the prison
for Andor all this time I can't swim
before they get that video game combo
[Music]
what an epic fall
and then there's fly off no I guess he's dead
oh my oh interesting did they make sure to
give him the the scar I feel like she would
notice something like that Happy Birthday
Mikey oh he took our baby Sean he took our
little boy
oh caught a bit of the conscience he's alive
caster
is already
everybody feels about the 500 percent uptick
in face touching at the office this week
man go to your mother's don't tell them where
you're going just go whoever you are don't
call again yeah yeah I'm down you know it's
true it's true here who's calling well if
you're Sean Archer I guess I'm Caster Troy
yes nice
epic drum fills this is like the perfect high
concept it's like it's such a simple cat and
mouse but with like the perfect sci-fi twist
it's like the stakes are just baked right
in so you're still selling Hobson and drugs
to Cheryl and Phil Roy
manuscript
Caster Troy wearing Sean Archer's face probably
doesn't care that much but like they're good
at giving Archer Troy these little ticks of
yeah just like ways in which he's not of this
world little suspicions I'm gonna get Sean
Archer he's vulnerable at home his house is
probably alarmed up the Wazoo code is 10 1986
that's his dead son's birthday I want to just
break your heart whoa oh my God how is it
that you know so much about showing auction
hi uh sleep with his wife oh my God
[Laughter] it's happening right now I'd like
to take his his face oh cool
his face oh the eyes
again it's coming off [Music] this is like
every actor's dream this movie like oh my
God just the amount of things to do and play
and oh
yeah there you go you're developing face swap
dementia
[Music] calm down calm down catch you later
yeah like Mr [__] invisible gives a [__]
about you anyway calm down whoa yeah
whoa
well
that aged kind of weird just giving the casting
dress up like Halloween and ghouls will try
to get in your pants
yeah good point wear whatever you want not
that even this is that like revealing anyway
full jacket pants do you have protection what
do you mean like
hahaha excellent transition next time let
Carl take his pants down slip this in his
thigh twist it
[Music] I
guess it's dice to know Caster Troy draws
the line somewhere I am the king I am the
king of domestic life expect me after all
this time just to just to jump on you is that
what you expect Jesus no I figured he might
drop it on some of our own friends bro and
if my eyes don't deceive I think this fellow's
beginning to enjoy being you props to the
guy who plays Pollocks too I mean Travolta
Nick Cage obviously get the Limelight but
uh oh oh no oh no little boy [Music] of course
he's yours too oh no oh no oh weird conflict
but of course
oh boy oh no
oh my God
Michael no it's Michael no no no no no no
no what's the matter with you
oh damn whoa oh no oh geez
that's a good idea baby listen to your music
oh we'll be over the rainbow with no time
wow
God always casings flying come on FBI step
it up for swatter whoever this is in conjunction
with [Music]
yes
[Laughter] pretty much Swiss cheese the entire
joint
[Music] wow nice
[Music] boy it's funny that I keep calling
him Kaz because we're at a point in Supernatural
where Kaz DL has body swapped somebody not
entirely dissimilar why why
wow no
but oh
yeah start knocking dudes out oh nice
[Music] a golden IPO V shot you know who it
is
no I hate the brain get out of here sure are
you all right go oh
oh wow let's do it hey man
[Music] yeah yeah what's your arterial spray
[Music]
let's go stand off let's do this stand off
you can't get back what you've taken from
me let's just kill each other yep oh perfect
yes
can you oh yes you can
remember who you're really shooting that's
great so silly but so Cinema I love it that's
my Venn diagram or cine meets silly yes
[Music]
God charred ass right there
climb boys yes [Laughter] [Music]
oh
brother sir why are you so upset it's just
Pollux Troy
wowie no that guy last night's bloodbath I'm
terminating your war on Terrace whoa what
I have something I want to confess yeah what
you do to him I am Caster Troy
ah yes you are it's weird it's it's badass
but it's not but it is but
fish [Music] last time I saw you was in this
room we had a fight when I said I had to go
away again oh no oh woman I'm so bad for her
oh my God it's a special ops surgeon gave
me uh casters
oh yeah and then somehow Castor came out of
his uh his coma and it killed everybody who
knew about the mission sure but not before
transforming into me
oh my God no amount of therapy will ever fix
any of this
oh oh beautiful Focus rack
oh yes I should love like the the hypersaturated
emotionality your husband me my Sean's blood
type is O Negative oh that's right I also
have more salt and pepper in my chest hair
it was our own diet today he had a heart seizure
whoa come to me I very much enjoy his his
Nick Cage his Caster Troy yes
seek the research woof Wowie ah that must
have been a very tiny little needle to not
uh you know produce that big of a sensation
[Music] [Laughter] careful yeah [Laughter]
thank you for trusting me maybe Sean's already
dead huh ah yeah I once took a date out for
surf and turf not knowing she was a vegetarian
oh and uh and broke her tooth on her right
seat oh we drove around all night uh looking
for a for a all-night dentist he was so drunk
I fixed the wrong twos what when I finally
brought her home I even though it must have
hurt like hell yeah you you kissed me oh go
to him I I can never make it up to you oh
you're damn well gonna try yes you'll find
the bastard
[Music] [Laughter]
oh where is he hiding what has got to think
when he said his wife runs off in the middle
of the night then I'm a doctor that's on call
so please let me get back to work okay sorry
supplies distrust mixed messages this is turning
into a real marriage [Music] [Laughter] I'll
give it to you kind of a bar sardonic bar
first Jamie that's what I'd like to know she
stole fifty dollars from my purse and took
off oh he killed my brother I'm not gonna
let him take you too I promise Sean Archer
is off your back for good interesting nice
we are here to celebrate the life of Victor
Lazaro and nominee Patrice the girls release
the girls there's got to be some white doves
like just around the corner somewhere
there they are yep we are officially Peak
woo
oh oh oh no
it's a message think about what you did
let's go
oh no [Music]
no chill honey honey oh of course there's
no way that wasn't gonna happen this is between
us leave them out of it yeah I'll do a repeat
of that one guy your son was an accident I
wanted to kill you but you took it so personally
why did you just kill yourself or Let It Go
my father could no brother could either neither
could his sister oh Sasha what the [__]
are you doing here G Arch I guess I'm crashing
I'm Caster that's Archer I'm bored oh boy
what a predicament how many this is like a
six-way standoff right now
yes it's on the eyes
duck yep nice [Music]
not in the Lord's House
what damn it's a very compact shootout
oh
damn that flip
[Music]
[Music] oh God
it's a cover oh no Wanda this is Steve Archer
wowie [Music] oh boy
oh boy please God died shut up honey don't
listen to him honey he's not your father hear
my voice I'm your father
whoa now we're gonna find out what's in Papa's
bag peaches oh Jesus say goodbye to Papa oh
yes
I should I should have thought that would
come back what a mess
[Laughter] oh my dude
sound effects too
cheaper's is quite an explosion I get every
second of that
whoa nice [Laughter] it's been a while since
I've seen some spirited boat stunts [Music]
God this is like that game of chicken at the
beginning except on the water now instead
of on our tarmac and with way more bloodshed
hahaha [Laughter]
yup get all that coverage that's awesome
but there's a lot of those after this a lot
of would-be Caster Troy swooping those up
[Music] whoa whoa damn dude the amount of
drag impressive whoa
careful with that drop it whoa you're gonna
clothesline the both of you
wow
that looks so painful oh this poor stunt guy
oh my God oh yep just
silly but awesome
wow
to other stunt performers [Music]
oh Jeepers I'm exhausted oh geez wow oh yeah
it looks painful oh
you know oh
every time you look in the mirror you can
see my face sure no oh no no no no oh geez
jigsaw why
wow end it with one more gift boy you okay
Archer
whoa what did you call me Paulie Archer sir
huh hanging in their tops receipt you're gonna
be okay
oh boy how much does the top surgical team
from DC know about all this theoretical sci-fi
face swappery walk is not that theoretical
but
yeah what matters
I won't need it anymore oh oh good because
we don't have that information anymore
[Music] come through the door looking like
Michael angel from the movie Michael not the
dead child of theirs I mean no disrespect
there's America's chin
oh all you two it's finally over
[Music] a regular girl again I'm here I'm
sorry I shot you [Music]
[__] face thing and so we have to ask
both of you
oh damn he needs a place to live hi
oh come on
okay
these two
okay ah
Joan Allen that's her name okay nice nicely
done whoo wow that was quite an experience
[Laughter] oh my God I am I I I I I need to
put my brain back together I need a moment
to just Center myself
[Music] that was truly a slice of slice of
the 90s man of the highest order like good
God what a wild experience I do not make them
quite like that any longer I I must say oh
boy oh it's beautiful okay you have to get
the get the heads head Twirl in there God
that whole bit with him is the priest that
was a Han Zimmer score fun when it's not busy
being like every you know piece of classical
music you've ever heard or church music Inferno
artist there's a there's a credit there's
a title for you air technicians certainly
for this movie printed on film
back when most all films were boy howdy people
we have quite a bit to talk about let's jump
into this let's chat [Music] I'm still uh
forgive me I'm still sort of reeling from
everything we just witnessed um but that that
was a blast you know this is a famously crazy
movie and I feel like every time I come into
one of these especially you know a movie like
this you know with like a Disney movie or
something like that there's like a different
sort of expectation and a different kind of
pressure in terms of what kind of enjoyment
you're gonna get out of it especially with
any movie that has you know particularly ingrained
just fan base or or reputation of any kind
um but this was yeah so much fun and and so
wild I mean this is the the kind of movie
I guess I I'm choosing to refer to now as
as fever cheese because uh it does have this
sort of madcap quality it does feels sort
of feverish in its just hyper saturation of
tone and emotion and just the way in which
everything is cranked up to like 15 like it's
very operatic and certainly John Wu brings
that sort of over-cranked quality where yeah
everything is just as Vivid as it could possibly
be and uh and yeah for the high concept at
the core of it and the the people I mean not
only the two star like of course the two stars
John Travolta Nicholas Cage uh bouncing off
each other but just the array as well of notable
that guys and character actors and just interesting
people popping up like this is a very colorful
and and bombastic movie in a way that's like
almost over it's quite overwhelming actually
but in a way that that yeah has this sort
of unbridled spirit that uh it's a cliche
now but like they they really don't seem to
make them like this very often anymore because
this is just so very much what it is it's
like it's like an unfiltered ID in a lot of
ways it's just you've got this classic setup
of you know this this murderous sociopath
Master criminal versus this you know fixated
uh just overly dedicated and moralistic well
not even moralistic I mean he's just so obsessed
with catching this guy Sean uh Archer that
yeah he's willing to go to any lengths he's
neglecting his family his life is sort of
all revolving around this and it's just about
these two sort of Polar Opposites you know
cat and mousing with each other and uh and
yeah I mean so much of it is just the you
know unique choices that they pour into it
and yes the high concept at the center of
it we're gonna have these two guys switch
cases so you have a you know Performance swap
essentially you get to watch as both Nick
Cage and John Travolta set up who uh Castor
Troy and Sean Archer are and then yeah the
fun I would say begins with the fun just begins
immediately because Nick Cave just chewing
all the scenery chewing through the frame
and like into the TV or whatever kind of border
is encapsulating the movie itself like he
is on a a wholly different plane and it's
fascinating to me that this movie works in
the way that it does as well as it does like
I don't know this is again I'm fascinated
to hear and discuss this with people to hear
more opinions and to discuss this with people
because it is certainly over the top and wild
and cheesy and and and sci-fi High Concept
in a way we're sure you know if you start
to poke too hard at any one piece of logic
or way they explain away certain aspects of
the general conceit I mean sure you're going
to come up with holes and all sorts of other
you know problems perhaps um but yeah I don't
know there's just something about this that
is everything that it needs to be like it
fully understands the assignment and yeah
I think it's a really fun exercise to watch
as the these two actors trade because I mean
they've got two very different acting Styles
and two different uh performances to emulate
and I think it's interesting to watch I mean
props to John Travolta like Nicholas Cage
and I think rightfully so is sort of in his
own universe and orbit for this entire experience
like he is even as Sean archer in a way he
is still kind of in his own pocket within
the rest of the you know electron cloud of
the movie the rest of the you know sort of
faculties that make this experience what it
is if you remove any of the different pieces
I think a lot of it would fall apart like
this is I think one of those moments where
the right combination of people collided to
really sell this and it's it's fun and interesting
because yeah I mean this Harkens back to a
time I mean it's certainly it's very much
of the 90s but it also reminds me some of
the pulp of the 80s as well it has almost
like a there's like a verhoveniness about
it you know there's some RoboCop in there
there's some of that sort of wacky sort of
Sly sardonic Edge coming from behind the camera
while you watch you know this High concept
chaos play out in the you know beats of the
story and all that but yeah just the way that
they balance each other out and the way that
you know earnestly uh John Travolta sets up
this Sean Archer guy I mean you're watching
him in the beginning moments in the most intimate
you know throws of Joy just you know enjoying
a day on the carousel at the park with his
kid Nick Cage with this freaking mustache
um and yeah you know like it's a classic setup
you know this assassination attempt gone awry
he loses his kid this starts a chain reaction
of obsession that will swallow his life and
strain his marriage and estrange him from
his daughter and send her down you know a
risky path and all that and the only way to
stop it the only way to get any kind of peace
is to put this guy away then to twist the
knife to come up with this scenario in which
yeah this bomb is planted and you know half
the equation half the puzzle half the info
we need is hidden and concealed because Castor
Troy goes into a coma Pollux Troy has the
rest of the information what do we do you
gotta go undercover as the guy you hate the
most in this world you have to wear his face
like it's a fascinating again vehicle for
fun and hijinks but it's also like intrinsically
sort of odd and uncanny and and messed up
and psychologically harsh and I do appreciate
the way that they played those aspects and
those elements because yeah it's like at first
you know John Travolta is anchoring this with
like the seriousness he's Batman basically
he's being Bruce Wayne he's dedicated to the
mission and you know he's trying to maintain
some kind of personal life or whatever but
mostly he just wants to take this guy down
once and for all he thinks he's maybe done
it but up turns out he's not dead and uh and
hey you uh you remember how I said you know
things were going to be different now because
uh you know the the chase is finally done
well they they pulled me back in just when
I thought I was out they pulled me back in
and uh and yeah watching them as they trade
characters is very gratifying because I don't
know from there the game is set I mean they
both translate the heart it's like while Nicholas
Cage and John Travolta each have very I would
say different acting Styles and that is certainly
the case it's on display here um they do manage
to like balance out the heart of this because
I mean John Travolta approaches Sean Archer
when he's just Sean Archer you know with a
certain level of just sincerity and then when
he's at work you know when he's on the job
you know he's very no-nonsense he's very focused
on the mission and then of course Nick Cage's
Caster Troy is just like again the unbridled
ID he's just completely debauched and anarchic
and gleeful and wild and he's just grabbing
everyone's ass and you know I mean yeah he's
he's just Hedonism incarnate he is very much
the Joker to Sean Archer's Batman essentially
than to watch him as he sort of has to Grapple
with the psychological torment of the mission
on Archer as Troy while I would say that John
Travolta gives the more like ground not to
call anything in this movie grounded but he
gives the more naturalistic performance I
guess and I thought he did a really nice job
at body and Caster Troy it's funny we're in
a period in Supernatural what uh watch alongs
and reaction highlights on patreon where not
exactly but there's a body swap-esque scenario
happening with one of the characters and they're
not you know the stakes and the details aren't
the same but the effect of the one character
inhabiting the other and then getting to watch
that actor emulate the other actor is uh is
one that I've very much I I can feel them
drawing inspiration from this because yeah
you have this guy in Caster Troy who is just
so mocking and jeering and such an imp and
so to watch Travolta then do that you know
180 and to inhabit him is really fun and gratifying
and I think he does a terrific job like his
is imp impressive for that I could feel the
amount of study and I think he's even said
that like yeah I mean you know my job was
a little easier and then I get to emulate
Nicholas Cage who has already even Justice
himself without all the extra you know expressionist
and Kabuki inspired acting techniques he's
already you know a pretty recognizable character
um so yeah for Nick Cage emulating John Travolta
I thought it was interesting it's a little
bit more of an impressionistic or or an expressionistic
approach in that it's not quite as naturalistic
as Travolta's doing him but I I don't know
like there's something about Nick Cage where
you're like he does have to do this weirder
job almost because Castor Troy doesn't care
about coming across as John Archer he you
know holds it together just enough he he pays
enough attention to just enough of the facts
and things to get by um but you know I guess
everybody's kind of noticing that he's behaving
differently and he's embracing this sort of
like this is a whole new me kind of thing
whereas Sean Archer as Castor Troy has a much
more difficult time slipping into the character
and I like that while there were times where
I was like don't you know this guy like better
than anyone though and wouldn't before doing
like it seems like he just he had that period
of like I'm definitely not gonna do this he
goes home he thinks about it a little bit
and he's like well this is the chance to put
the final nail on the coffin so I I guess
I'll I'll do it uh but you know I feel like
we missed a whole period of time where he
would have done some a little bit more studying
just dystopian character uh but you know I
grad they also don't have time for that given
the time bomb that is literally going to go
off in several days um so yeah you know watching
him infiltrate the prison and be sort of reluctant
to inhabit the role of Castor Troy I think
was a fun thing and something that Nicholas
Cage did handle very strikingly like again
even if his acting style is more Broad and
is encompassing of less naturalistic approaches
I do think he did a really fun and interesting
job of showing the anguish of Sean Archer
though a bit broadly perhaps uh still you
know selling it earnestly and then you know
really kind of relishing in a different kind
of wildness as he has to sort of play the
the weird like mental dissonance and perhaps
sort of breakdown that needs to happen as
Sean Archer surrenders to this process to
it habit Caster Troy at least well enough
to get some information from his brother and
you know navigate through this prison which
again I guess Andor must have taken some big
inspiration from that with the whole uh electromagnetic
floors and it being out at Sea and all that
stuff it's fun it's fun to see uh even on
this first watch just touch Stones where I've
seen this movie referenced in other places
because certainly it has been quite influential
over time but yeah even those little nuances
like the way Pollux is clearly suspect of
Caster when he first arrives at the prison
you know he's very subdued he's not behaving
you know in the manner that Caster Troy has
behaved up until this point and who better
to pick up on something like that being off
than his own brother and a character who has
been well established as being very close
to him both intellectually but also emotionally
certainly and and props to Alessandro navola
just for keeping up with and playing off of
especially Nicholas Cage because you know
you have John Travolta Nick Cage at the center
there the spotlight performances but I think
the Supporting Cast goes a long way to pinning
down and grounding the rest of the movie around
them and yeah I thought he really just naturally
played as this guy's you know brilliant but
more subdued younger brother and I loved the
way that his Gaze on Archer Troy you know
creates this tension as he tries to infiltrate
and get the information that he needs because
you never get the sense that he is entirely
convinced of what he is seeing even though
you know you don't think he's gonna you know
come to the conclusion that some kind of sci-fi
procedure has taken place yeah they just they
just always kind of Leave You uneasy that
like his brother can tell and I really like
the way that they then use the meme during
that prison fight you know where Caster looks
up at Pollux which by the way uh excellent
choice of names caster and Pollux the uh the
mythical twins Gemini I see you and I'm here
for it justice from a Gemini is out there
I know you get a bad rap uh but yeah the way
he's like looking up at him and it clearly
Dawns like oh I cannot be wearing the anguish
and the weight of this ordeal in my face I
can't be looking like I'm on the verge of
tears and like flinching every time I come
across a guy who Sean Archer put in jail here
who I'm about to be spending some very close
quarters time with I gotta give myself over
to the assignment to the character to the
ruse and yeah then watching as he sort of
goes from this realization to them like okay
yeah I gotta get nuts you know and and watching
as he then subsequently you know sort of forms
his own version of what being Castor Troy
is like I like that yeah they don't just become
each other full on and and you even get the
sense of like did did he do enough research
to be able to sell this it seems like you
know once he recanted on his initial turning
down of the assignment uh he kind of just
launched right into it and I know he knows
a lot about this guy but at the same time
it seems like there was some homework left
on the table but either way they both kind
of assume each other's lives and then in ways
you can't call it improving them but they
you know sort of fill in gaps where things
were missing or at least sort of bring into
heavy relief the things that were missing
and I mean you know in in Sean Archer's life
a lot of that comes across in some very creepy
intimate moments with uh Eve especially Joan
Allen's character who I thought she I felt
so bad for her but I thought she did a really
nice job and she had a lot of poison Grace
as this you know innocent caught up in this
terrible sordid Twisted web of circumstance
um and then Dominic Swain as well uh you know
very uncomfortable you know wholly different
way when Troy Archer is like you know getting
uncomfortably close to her and stuff like
that while he's pretending to be cool dad
I guess um but yeah having like the the sheer
unsettling quality of that and then him going
into the office and you know using his own
crime to elevate his version of Sean Archer's
profile to be like you know top FBI agent
freaking Time Magazine person of the year
and then meanwhile you have Archer Troy who
you know is only doing like the things that
he absolutely has to in order to embody this
guy and then also kind of like trying to be
a better guy about it like that whole thing
with Gina Gershon who I also really liked
in this where she's like coming onto him in
the bedroom and uh he's like clearly very
uncomfortable with that and he basically rebukes
her in that moment and you know you get the
sense that yeah like regular Caster Troy he
would probably be all about this um but you
know he seems to actually kind of extends
some kind of sympathy towards her that she
does pick up on and that creates sort of an
interesting Turning Point wherein she starts
to look upon him in a different way and I
mean it's not actually Castor Troy growing
as a human being but for her it sort of is
which is just again another interesting weird
little Nuance that then yeah blossoms outward
into uh Archer as Troy looking out for her
and then ultimately opening the door for him
to adopt Young Adam and bring everything full
circle at the end when you know Hollywood
morality dictates that uh that Mom has to
die and I mean you know she has a certain
tragedy to her character as well just because
yeah I mean she is clearly In Too Deep with
Caster Troy and his whole organization and
whatever her weird relationship is with her
brother like yeah I think she has a really
nice presence and is a very nice Counterpoint
to Eve while also yeah opening the door up
for a very sort of poetic and very kind of
Hollywood romantic uh wrap up for this core
wound that exists within the character of
Sean Archer to the point that he literally
you know at the end decides to erase that
core woo he doesn't need the core wound anymore
the wound is healed the wound he has been
so particular about throughout the whole film
which did they bother to put that on Sean
Archer Caster Troy when he got the face put
on what he have known that like because I
feel like Eve would have definitely noticed
something like that but anyway you know the
literal closing of the core wound nice but
yeah man just like so many great uh little
guest stars and uh and and that guy actors
and things like that I mean you got Nick cassavetes
you got comb fiori John Carroll Lynch CCH
Pounder Robert wisdom Matt Ross freaking Margaret
Cho uh who was like again another one of those
people who brings me right back to this moment
in time this had such a fun and interesting
array of just weird little human quirks and
things like that on top of all just the opulent
set design and costuming and music and the
action of course I mean this is a John Wu
film John Woo excels certainly is certainly
renowned for his action and I'm sitting here
going why in God's green earth was mission
Impossible too so not this I mean not that
it should be exactly this but that movie is
sort of famously and perhaps egregiously sort
of dull for all of the you know fun and interesting
things it has going for it and yeah you look
at something like this and you're like this
is like an anime come to life in a lot of
ways I mean it has so many of those classic
tropes as well which those are also borrowing
from various you know movie and Hollywood
and other Traditions too but yeah you just
have this like extreme height of every tone
no matter what scene you're in like it certainly
is most obvious during the action scenes where
everyone's like dual wielding and they're
doves flying by and seagulls in certain cases
yeah you've got like a helicopter chasing
a plane on the tarmac with a bunch of cars
and then they're all crashing into a hangar
and then you know at the end you've got a
speed boats chasing each other and you've
got you know them fighting them as each other
and then them fighting them as themselves
and all sorts of different switcheroos and
and I mean the action certainly is stylish
and it's fun to see it all on film certainly
more obvious I think when you have stunt doubles
doing certain things but yeah there's so many
interesting little set pieces that take place
in all these different unique locations and
whatnot uh and then you know the LA Convention
Center getting a lot of play for crime movies
in the mid 90s and going for that sort of
sweeping epic classical music you know this
sort of irony of Castor Troy as again this
sort of unbridled monster but who has this
sort of hoity-toity taste just the same um
you know then the title it's just so well
chosen you know obviously first off but they're
facing off and then at the end you've got
them facing off literally divided by a wall
each looking into a mirror talking to each
other so that they're looking upon the face
they're truly talking to even though they're
wearing it like it's such a like it's one
of those movies where like to describe it
makes you sound like you're on drugs and I
think that's a really fun thing and yeah this
is why one of those movies that I think just
gets by on the blunt force of its convictions
and of its commitment again to every Tone
It attempts to inhabit like when it's being
an action movie it's being a hundred and fifteen
percent in action movie when it's doing something
intimate and perhaps romantic or at least
you know sort of longing in a in a romantic
kind of way it is a 115 percent that sort
of romance novel level of Pulp and commitment
uh when it's about you know crazy Globe trotting
maniacal sociopathic criminals it is 115 that
weird kind of thing and and it commits you
know with like the full range I think that's
that's why the cheese works is because it
is fully committed in such a hammy kind of
way like everybody kind of seems no matter
how subtle or not they're playing it to realize
that's the movie they're in and the more I
sit here the more I think about it the more
the this does really feel like some kind of
anime where you know you have these two archetypical
characters these two Paragons of two different
philosophies aimed at one another who were
just not going to stop until one or both of
them is dead and gone for good and yeah just
like the way the again emotionality is infused
into everything and the way everything is
just as Vivid and saturated and heightened
as it could possibly be like yeah this is
like I would posit this as like one of the
best live-action animes that isn't an anime
just because the more I sit here the more
I take it all in I'm like yeah that's exactly
what we just saw like like you throw a rotoscope
over this and these are like the character
types the weird you know situations that unfold
the weird violations of you know people's
personal space and his social contracts in
general and the you know just chaotic array
of details that comprise each one of the these
characters in the world that they live in
and the slight sci-fi flourishes that the
movie has beyond all that because it's not
even that sci-fi but it is but it's not you
know like the central conceit is but it's
not really taking place in a world that feels
very far beyond our own so yeah man like this
is just such a fascinating Moment In Time
a time capsule most certainly and one of those
I think special movies where just the right
people coalesced at the right time and all
got on the same page together and committed
to I mean something that with a with a concept
where if you do half a good job something
entertaining should come of this but yeah
then you get all of these talents and all
these people who are clearly inclined to embrace
the opportunity and the challenge of just
going completely all in and over the top I
mean yeah I can see why this has the meme
and cult and classic status that it does and
I had an absolute blast so guys leave me your
thoughts anything you want to point out anything
I might have missed and uh yeah let me know
what other movies you might want to see reactions
to uh I haven't seen Con Air that's another
Nick Cage joint I could check out there are
probably a few Nick Cage joints out there
that I still need to catch up with but uh
but yeah I'm so glad to have finally seen
this and to have been able to share this first
watch with you uh just I could go on forever
with the craziness of this movie but I think
that's that's all the main stuff that ought
to be said So yeah thank you for joining me
if you've joined me leave a like on the video
subscribe and all that good stuff and last
but not least let's do a patreon of the day
shout out
Andrew Hayes listen Andrew if there's anybody
at the patreon whose face I'd like to take
off and swap out for my own it's you Andrew
you have been one of our most loyal you know
us better than most people out there do or
could possibly hope to imagine and that's
why I want to assume you're alive I feel like
you know enough about me that you could slip
in undetected all we would need is to change
faces we're pretty close and similar in body
type and that way I could walk a mile in your
shoes maybe improve your living a little bit
you know try my hand at your life as a as
a creative person in a locksmith and you can
come here here and make big reactions you
know what I mean so uh Andrew the further
I go this this Nick Cage is kind of falling
apart um but hey buddy thank you for being
here for all the love that you've shown us
over so much time you know we don't get to
catch up often but it's always great when
we do and I hope you're doing well out there
and uh yeah whose face do you want to take
off man let me know and uh we'll catch you
on the next one much love cheers foreign